افاد موقع ول الاسرائيلي ان اجتماع المجلس
الوزاري الاسرائيلي المصغر انتهى عقب
خلافات حاده بين رئيس الاركان ووزراء بسبب
تشكيل فريق للتحقيق باحداث السابع من
اكتوبر واضاف الموقع ان الجلسه شهدت مشدات
حاده وصراخ ما دفع رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
الى ايقاف الجلسه واوضح موقع ولا ان وزراء
بالمجلس المصغر هاجموا رئيس هيئه الاركان
هرتس هاليفي بسبب تعيين شاؤول مفاز الذي
اشرف على خطه الانسحاب من غزه على راس
فريق التحقيق من جانبها ذكرت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه ان مسؤولين في المستوى
العسكري غادروا اجتماع المجلس المصغر بعد
هجوم الوزراء على رئيس
الاركان من تل ابيب ينضم الينا مراسل
الجزيره محمد خيري محمد ما الاجواء التي
تحيط بهذا المجلس بعد انتهائه خاصه في ظل
هذه الخلافات
الحاده بالفعل خلافات كبيره ومشدات حصلت
بين الوزراء من جهه ورئيس هيئه الاركان
الاسرائيلي ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
والوزير بين جانس ايضا من جهه ثانيه حسب
التسريبات الاسرائيليه التي يعني صدرت قبل
قليل و نشرت بعضها وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
فان الجلسه كانت حاميه الوطيس وقد اضطر
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
الى قطع هذه الجلسه وهناك تسريبات ايضا
تشير الى ان الموضوع الاساسي الذي عقدت
هذه الجلسه من اجل بحثه وهو غز ما بعد
الحرب الاسرائيليه وكيف سيكون المشهد في
قطاع غزه لم يبحث ابدا رغم ان هذه الجلسه
كانت يعني منتظره منذ عده ايام لدى
المستويات السياسيه والامنيه والعسكريه
الاسرائيليه وهي تاتي عقب جلسه عقدت في
نفس السياق في خلال لمجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي اذا هذا يعني جزء من الخلافات
الاسرائيليه الحاده بين المستويات
المختلفه الوزراء وعلى راسهم الوزير بن
كفير اتهم يعني او رفض دعينا نقول تعيين
شاؤول مفاز وهو وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
السابق والذي يقول بن كفير انه اشرف على
خطه الانسحاب من قطاع غزه عام 2005 وكذلك
قال عدد من الوزراء الاسرائيليين انه ليس
وقت البحث في فشل المنظومه الاسرائيليه
خلال السابع من اكتوبر انما هو وقت الحرب
الاسرائيليه هذا جزء من الخلافات
الاسرائيليه حقيقه هناك خلافات واضحه بدات
يعني تطفو على السطح كل يوم بشكل اكبر
وخاصه بين رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
نتنياهو ووزير دفاعه يوف جالنت والذي يعني
اليوم هو ايه ايه عمم خطه او سربها دعينا
نقول لوسائل الاعلام لانها حاليا
ليست خطه يعني مؤكده او مصادق عليها من
قبل المستويات والجهات الاسرائيليه
المختصه وهي خطه غزه ما بعد الحرب وكيف
تراها وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه في بعض
بنود هذه الخطه يوضح جلنت ان القسم يعني
قسمها الاول سيبدا في شمال قطاع غزه
وسيشمل عمليات اغتيال وتصفيه جويه وكذلك
اقتحامات موضعيه للجيش الاسرائيلي وهدم
انفاق المقاومه الفلسطينيه بينما ستستمر
العمليه العسكريه في مدينه خانيونس جنوبي
القطاع وذلك من اجل الوصول كما يقول
لقيادات حركه حماس وكذلك اعاده الاسرى
الاسرائيليين ايضا هذه الخطه يعني وجدت
معارضه من قبل كثير من الوزراء حقيقه في
اسرائيل وعلى راسهم وزير الماليه بيتسل
ايس مترش الذي قال انها تحاكي ما قبل
السابع من اكتوبر وليس الوضع ال راهن في
قطاع غزه وذهب سموتريتش ايضا الى الدعوه
مره اخرى الى ان الدعوه دعينا نقول الدعوه
الى تشجيع سكان قطاع غزه ان صح التعبير
على الهجره من القطاع كذلك كانت هناك
تسريبات تشير الى ان وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي اتهم نتنياهو بانه يضر بامن
اسرائيل وذلك بعد التسريبات لوسائل
الاعلام والتي اشارت الى ان نتنياهو قد ع
وزير دفاعه من لقاء رئيس جهاز المساد
وكذلك لقاء جهاز الامن العام الشباك خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه لبحث المجريات العمليه
العسكريه في قطاع غزه وكذلك لبحث واقع غزه
ما بعد الحرب وهو الامر الذي كان يرفضه
نتنياهو طيله الوقت